[Musique]
s est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
denis ktf bonjour bonjour merci pérou
pour les habitations mais merci à vous
d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes russe
vous êtes journaliste vous travaillez
pour la chaîne russe privé d'opposition
doj de qui a été suspendue interdite de
diffusion de tous les médias russes
indépendant voilà comme par le kremlin
donc le 3 mars dernier une semaine après
le début de l'invasion de l'ukraine je
précise que c'est une chaîne
d'information payante qui aimait sur
internet vous avez quitté la russie
denis kamaev quelques jours avant que
votre chat ne soit suspendue en russie
d'autres journalistes russes ont fait le
choix de rester en russie à quel moment
vous vous êtes dit que le risque était
trop grand pour vous en tant que
journaliste de rester à moscou merci
j'ai décidé quitté la russie à troisième
jour de la guerre après le début de la
guerre parce que j'ai prévu la situation
et pour moi c'est être clair que c'est
impossible d'être un journaliste
indépendant aussi hein parce que a le
loi à contre la liberté d'expression
contre les journalistes contre
les gens qui
veulent manifester dans les roues
étaient adoptées par le loi n'a pas par
le parlement russe c'était la loi contre
fake news contre les informations
mensongères a on ne peut pas utiliser
juste le mug guerre
c'est impossible utiliser juste le mot
guerre c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé que
c'est impossible de travailler et de
vivre à 1 en russie et pour moi-même
aussi parce que c'est pas
à cause de danger c'est à cause de moi
même ma caution parce que c'est pas
possible c'est impossible de travailler
et de vivre dans le pays agresseur pour
moi même pourtant les restrictions à la
liberté d'informer en russie ne date pas
du début de l'invasion de l'ukraine qui
a commencé
avant un
[Musique]
2014 parce que là après l'annexion de la
craignait beaucoup de loi est adopté et
on a nommé comme les gens à travers ses
agents de l'étranger de l'argent de
l'étranger vous êtes en france depuis un
mois et demi hébergé par nos confrères
qu'on salue de radio france et merci
paul la radio france voilà vous
travaillez dans les locaux de radio
france vous êtes toujours journalistes
bien sûr et vous diffuser de
l'information depuis paris à destination
de la russie expliquez nous comment
parce que on a décidé de continuer à
travailler ici en europe c'est très
important pendant la guerre parce que on
a senti
le bi zoua et les demandes d'information
indépendant il ya beaucoup de gens qui
restent en russie pour l'instant comment
mr peut-être
c'est un privilège de quitter la russie
de fuir la russie pour l'instant mais
beaucoup de gens qui pensent
différemment qui contre la guerre qui
contre poutine mais c'est impossible à
s'exprimer c'est impossible il n'y a pas
de voir des angles comme ça des gens qui
pensent différemment c'est juste la
propagande russe qui existe et on peut
être accusé à 15 ans de prison si tu
manifestants mais aussi pourquoi il y à
hambye gens parce que à 1 par exemple à
diffuser pendant une semaine juste après
le début de la guerre on a gagné plus de
20 5 millions de view chaque jour juste
sur youtube il ya beaucoup des gens il
ya beaucoup de gens qui passent
différemment il ya beaucoup de gens qui
un bilan besoin d'information
indépendant c'est pourquoi on a décidé
qu'on y est on a crié à on va crier on
va créer à les bureaux partout en europe
les bureaux de poste ce sera le d'offre
globale peut être le réseau des
journalistes en du pana moi je suis à
paris je veux créer le studio ont mis le
bureau à paris ah les autres
journalistes en allemagne peut-être pays
bas les pays baltes on va crier le
réseau des journalistes indépendants et
on va continuer à travailler d'ici en
europe en anglais pour combattre à la
propagande russe et pour changer
l'opinion publique en russie voilà parce
que pour l'instant on dit que 70 % des
russes soutiennent l'admirent poutine
est ce que ce chiffre vous paraît
réaliste et qu'est ce que les russes en
réalité soutiennent
en fait il n'a pas des vrais chiffres en
russie pour l'ensemble parce que il n'a
pas de sociologie n'a pas de politique
et c'est juste le kremlin qui décide
c'est pourquoi moi je ne crois pas aux
chiffres mais je crois que il y a le
mérite et la mènerai progressif dans les
villes et dans les grandes villes à
moscou à saint-pétersbourg
les gens le classe moyens à les gens
éduqués il y a beaucoup de gens à qui a
formé à la minorité progressif et moi je
crois et je suis sûr que toujours dans
l'histoire que minorité progressif qui
change l'histoire c'est pourquoi il a
les minorités russes progressif existe
en russie je crois que on peut changer
pas à pas
l'opinion publique en russie c'est
possible cette bataille-là vladimir
poutine ne l'a pas la gagner pour
l'instant et on a les journalistes on
est le journaliste indépendant on va
créer à en europe ici d'ailleurs la
russie a le mouvement à
résistance contre charles de gaulle
général de gaulle
était créé écrire à londres à la radio
oui et on va trier comme ça le mouvement
résistance des journalistes indépendants
on va préparer
le plan pour la nouvelle russie pour
changer pourtant aujourd'hui en russie
ici je suis russe et que je ne veux pas
croire à ce que me raconte le kremlin je
peux je peux vous écouter sur télégramme
je peux regarder des chaînes
indépendantes pourquoi est ce que les
russes dans la grande majorité de ne le
font pas parce que la propagande est
très forte en russie et la télé couleur
plus de
90%
un de turquie toi oui ces territoires
c'est difficile pour a
à la campagne les villages banlieue mais
j'ai déjà dit que granville la
population les gens de granville pensent
différemment et bien évidemment que la
minorité des grands ville va changer
l'histoire toujours ça émond jacques roy
à ça et c'est pourquoi pour moi c'est
mes collègues c'est évidemment quand on
va on doit continuer à travailler pour
les gens qui restent en russie ça fait
un peu plus d'un mois que vous êtes ici
à paris en france comment est-ce que
vous jugez le traitement médiatique qui
est fait ici en france qui est réservé à
la guerre en ukraine et en particulier
autour du cas de vladimir poutine moi je
pense que
monnet le marron le président de la
république a fait beaucoup jouent par le
traitement médiatique médiatique
les
comme à l'échelle et la presse française
ici traite de laroui bien sûr c'est mon
je pense que c'est c'est vrai c'est oui
pensez vous que vladimir poutine va
s'arrêter à l'ukraine non je pense que
c'est la menace pour tous celles et
menace pour l'europe c'est la menace
pour
les occidentaux pour
tout le monde parce que
malheureusement les menace de la guerre
nucléaire existe oui
et c'est pourquoi tous les
à
dire j'en ai européenne comprend ça
c'est pourquoi un c'est pourquoi c'est
difficile pour négocier avec monsieur
poutine c'est pourquoi il faut continuer
à essayer de parler avec lui parce que
c'est la menace existe et il faut
prendre sur il faut maintenir le
dialogue il faut maintien et le dialogue
c'est pourquoi je dis que pour moi c'est
le stratégie du michel maffrand c'est
vrai le soir de l'invasion de l'ukraine
denis ktef vous avez posté sur votre
compte instagram bandeau noir intitulé
pardonnez-nous pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez utilisé cette se prononce le nous
parce que vous pensez que dans le monde
il y as peut-être un sentiment
antirusse qui pourrait monter s'exprimer
ce que vous le ressentez d'ailleurs ici
en famille bien sûr parce que tout tous
les rousses sont responsables parce que
c'est
la responsabilité générale et moi je
suis en paix
moi j'ai honte j'ai honte ce d'isoler
pour moi
il faut il faut pratiquer un peu noire
géante parce que
moi j'adore la russie mais moi je je
sens que facebook ne manquent pas ce que
moi je suis moscovite me
manque beaucoup mais
c'est le patrimoine de moi est ce moi je
suis rousse et moi je suis responsable
de ça mais je voudrais faire c'est
pourquoi je voudrais faire nous que joe
e pour éviter la guerre et pour changer
les pilot public c'est très important
après poutine pour l'instant non bon je
voudrais vivre en france je voudrais
continuer comme journaliste indépendant
et je voudrais continuer retrouvé de
travail et de vivre ici merci messieurs
si possible justement
mon parcours on en rit on continue à
travailler ici à paris en afrique on a
déjà ouvert le bureau à paris moi je
voudrais inviter monsieur macron le
président de la république
compte invité sur plateau à l'antenne de
dosches si possible
vous écoute beaucoup merci à vous merci
denis cat est revenu ce matin sur ce
plateau le plateau de paris dira